foreign
[Music]
okay now the move is h3o and then Bishop
this okay it goes B3 it's actually now
hard not to do it
that was pretty clutcho I agree
I agree I agree oh
but now I thought well
[Music]
five
Seiko Takeo
sacrifice
no it doesn't work though
it doesn't work maybe a five
-0
yeah if I do the entire Speed Run in
this voice I think people will like
murder me
yeah he freaking seal everything we need
to
God freaking girl
whoops let one slipped there
let's go back
I just gotta go cancel out for that oh
that's a very battle
foreign
this is pretty this is getting out of
control we need to stop about this
immediately though
this is getting quite annoying
[Music]
never heard me curse in English
yeah no explanation just put this on
YouTube and just let people figure it
out
I mean somebody would explain it in the
in the comment section pretty quickly I
think
but it would be funny
and I'm struggling on taimo again
um ammo
ammo
I like that one
no that was bad
come on Daniel move
D again I'm low on time though
constantly out
constantly alone Timo
so trachio
foreign
93
.
oh my gosh Knight F3 Rook H2
you freaking kidding me
freak
no no no no no no no no no no no he
freaking wondered
here
might go under there massage
it's a beautiful move but I don't think
it works
I mean I was just low on time that's
kind of the kind of thing that happens
when you're in time pressure
wait you missed it he was winning on the
spot there
it's just oh [ __ ] oh my queen was
singing
oh I didn't even see that I guess I go
here now
here
here
wait It's Not Over
not over row
[ __ ]
why did he do that oh
make its draw
a winner with yellow this is crazy oh
flago
despite a blunder of multiple times
it's funny how long we're sustaining
this
is the movo computer recommendo
you can beat Hikaru Hikaru out in this
Lino but
Castle Law
I should talk like this the next time
I'm commentating anything wrong wow
[Music]
actually I'm quite frankly I mean wow I
mean I mean it actually is wrong I mean
I mean if I'm being totally on a cereal
like oh my God
oh my God
what is this move
yeah like what if I just like freaking
go F5 and just like
freaking smash him
it might be the last time I get hired
out yeah because
my higher down canceled though
immediately oh
Danny Ren show will not be happy if I do
that do that oh
that's fine
I have to get hired Alicia so
foreign
would find it funnier but not yeah for
for a little while and then it would be
like all right what the [ __ ] are you
doing
um wait oh let's think oh I have time
out
valentio
it's winning I'm sure but it's super
complicated version of this I could lose
this and I wouldn't be too upset
look it's real
lift all the Roku perhaps so
what do you think about that oh
okay yeah
I guess he has Bishop G5 here Bishop G5
Mr G5 Queen f8
yeah
goes there immediately
I guess I'd made
Oh I thought Bishop no I thought Bishop
G5 okay it's not the end of the world I
have to trade Queens I thought I had Mr
G5 Bishop F7 but
but um I should have gone Bishop F7
first that was just game over oh my gosh
literally Bishop F7 game over
wait let's not panic must be a way to
win this
oh my gosh I got too excited
okay whatever you know what I'm just
gonna freaking take here
it's not the end of the world I'm still
better
and we're still gonna win
foreign
I think
let's go away
um
foreign
foreign
which is not the end of the world
seriously
foreign
foreign
yes
I mean I was totally winning so I think
it's a fair result
but blank yeah I was like pretty
impressive lagging if I may say so
myself
uh yeah
that was probably more tilting for him
than if he would have lost so we'll take
it
I mean I was doing every I was pulling
out every trick
that was that I think that was a good
time scrambling to both of us
okay but let's not lose our
concentration now
because oh
so good Oak Macho and we don't wanna
Rono this is stupido Gamo
I guess so
how am I adopting government I'm just
playing pretty well if I may say so my
cell phone
um
this I'm worth so
we're so Poland
okay don't don't tell me he's gonna take
with a pawn here
is he actually gonna take up the phone
no he goes there I thought I can play
three
drop it back hit the Pawns
suddenly oh I like my position here
but not really
hmm let's think
an idea that I'm familiar with in such
Physicians
is to play King f8 and King G8 at least
I think my king is a little safer there
yeah but I'm busted
in the long run I'm kind of busted here
so I just have no counter play that's
the problem maybe Rook F5 should be
considered even
like that's how bad it is
I just
I need to be alert to Tactical
opportunities and and wait for him to
come after me
um
okay let's go here
literally like there's nothing I can do
um
run
waddle you blunder of the pot out Carlo
girl
what are you doing though
no no no no girl oh there's no way oh
this will work so
you have to refuto
Where is the refuto
shadow
see the draw
no no oh whoa
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] now
wait here oh no it meets me there
what a beautiful mate
that's gorgeous I mean if I go there he
mates me with Queen F6 queen h8 I'm six
well what a game
this is
a nice little save there
is this
okay so H6
it is a draw
I it is a driving Queen C1 and better
only move but that was impossible
thank you Bubba
there's a lot of queeno okay those good
two good saves let's turn it around
again let's win
okay what am I doing
there was there was
what the heck is an accuracy speed run
aren't all my speedruns aiming for
accuracy
I mean
unless unless I have it wrong
I would play better in the SEC if it was
at 3am
and you know it
the later the better
[Music]
can you believe about that gamer I mean
that was crazy
foreign
[Music]
to temptational
danger California are there any other
types of Californians
did you give up to everything I'm very
real estate don't have any left I mean
okay let's take
it's
uglio but I have the bishop so and I
think I have some chances though
on the king cider
maybe a hero
Taco somehow
but I freaking blundered though again oh
stupid oh
but I can take oh
man worse worse so
definitely white is worse here
and this matches it was going my way but
now I feel like there's been a momentum
shift
and he's been out playing me the last
couple games
he's gonna go Queen C4 I know this guy
freaking out for to save so well
I know his Stylo
I'm gonna push him infiltrator
foreign
where is my win God damn it
whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa this is has to be
losing
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no no no no no that was a terrible move
oh my gosh
no it's not time service I know
oh no I'm just shooting I'm shooting the
bed
oh my gosh
I managed to lose this or no not to lose
it
totally shot the bend there
foreign
did not resign though
that was very dirty oh I had to window
with some very dirty old play oh because
I my technique was horrible
I thought oh he was I know but he didn't
resign though he just kept playing go
and I didn't know what to do
but important thing was I didn't panic
when I was lost I think I managed to
keep my composure
and I found oh the besto Lino
wait this is like a four nights I think
you can actually leave the bishop there
okay we need to win on the next game oh
as well oh because it would be nice so
okay let's go here here
okay it's playing really really quickly
I don't like his speed of his freaking
play
no that was terrible move
okay terrible might be a number
statement it was terrible this Barclays
is terrible
the problem is when FedEx gets Maddie
actually starts playing much better
um let's release the tension a little
bit
then 95 this move though
whoa
whoa
hold your horses please
I don't believe in anything how he's
doing right now
over here in the South we talk about we
Kings
heard of that concept before week week
King
I have and I know
what I'm worth here
maybe you should have gone King H7
probably should have gone King H7
shadow
I guess he go Gozo Bishop d500 which I
missed though but
it's okay of course of course so he
seeso
quinnage
yeah it takes the 64.
[Music]
actually takes is interesting
hmm
gosh it's complicated but okay I'll just
do this no time
no this is bad IAA
how is this a thing
yeah very unfortunate there
I don't think I'm losing though
that was really unlucky though he had
that trick with C4 okay let's not lose
my head here let's keep the Queens on
the board because that's my only chance
otherwise I'd get flagged let's beat his
ass
building no
check out
Keiko no Perpetual or is there maybe
perpetual
well there is perpetual
um
check
check
oh my god oh
[ __ ]
I don't see it I don't see it Queen B2
is Perpetual yeah no there's nothing
it's only -2 I'm in the right decision
unbelievable that's so unfortunate
I had Queen G3 but I didn't have
anything here I couldn't take the bishop
because he has Queen A8
that's very unfortunate this is actually
oh I have Knight F5 and she's sick but
okay I won't be able to win this
so I actually made the decision to
to not try to get flagged even though I
I usually am good on time against him
I don't really like to go crazy
I'm trying to be a little bit more
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no what was what was ba oh my goddamn
what was that Mom it's really not the
end of the world
in fact 92 is maybe even the best move
but
yeah
okay but wait
here we go back
I'm gonna just play fast though
and playing fast here
do what do I think is this a command
because normally I don't accept commands
because
I decide what to do on my stream but
if you would like to hear with me
certainly don't mind because right now I
normally will charge some subscriptions
but today I'm feeling generous soon
and we'll be doing the phrase subscribe
free impersonations
and I really don't mind doing it because
this very good community
but normally I don't do it unless you
know
unless you pay the money
but I blunder The Rook takes C3 but then
I have Queen takes system and
we can try the to play D5 okay f65 and I
think I'm winning a new game
foreign
because if I go Rook A7 he tried to get
the square yeah
now Knight C7
trying to keep time run I mean I mean
it's problem man man I guess it's just a
Magnus mag is really into the free
framing when push comes to shove you
know okay let's try this
another is sex
oh my gosh I blundered 95.
bungle the toilet bungled it
it's Charlie Charlie Bungalow it's
totally bungle it's totally bungalish
totally bungle it
it's absolutely bungle it's totally
bundled it
it's completely bungalish totally
bungled it
yeah I did miss Knight E5 by the way
all seriousness let's see if he finds it
no he does not okay
okay I should be winning here
I think Knight C7 makes sense Knight A3
really don't know what to do
let's go Knight back
won't mind
E6 and of course I'm Leonard yum
I'm 100 Knight C6
oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna win this game I
guess
completely winning I totally outplayed
him there but now I'm still up a pawn
but he's gotten his pieces out quite a
bit
but I can still I mean we are we are
playing bull again and I'm up on time so
I could try flat fly flying the normal
class classical game I wouldn't fly him
but in book and it's a different story
Diana
um okay let's go here he's gonna go
Bishop H6 isn't he
okay let's freaking get this get rid of
this fricker
fricker
um
he wants 94 so I don't want to allow it
don't Flander a fork that's the one rule
no forks and no bad free moves
foreign
never remember the move here like I
literally like literally I like
literally never remember oh my God
I think it's D5 but I'm really not sure
girl
whoa that is like a crazy mess
okay
he's literally higher rated than me and
fide what are you saying
he's like a hundred points higher than
me so he's above my size
maybe I'll find someone who's actually
my rating next time
sorry
troll failed
yeah I'll put this up on YouTube and
people will be like
the favorite refrain of everybody on
Twitter
so you have Knight F7
really Riley
really Riley
Riley really
I guess he does have Knight F7 wow this
is a crazy position
hmm
complicated
yeah I thought I have Rook F3 but then
he goes rookie six Rick B3 rookie seven
wait why am I worse there
oh [ __ ] he just takes oh okay but the
good news is
I forgot I can do that the good news is
I have compensation for the exchange
that's the good news
if I play this carefully I think this is
the move
I forgot I forgot that you can just play
GF because the queen is undefended
that's the point
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh but oh I have some chances
though a knight of five oh no
if
you
go
okay wait
um [ __ ] I had Knight H4 didn't I
let's go here
stopping rookie seven
okay now we have to take
trying to push these freaking phones
thank you
no back
[Music]
um
it's so easy to make progress here is it
foreign
guys
that was an amazing game because I
sacked The Exchange and I didn't lose my
mind
foreign
oh it's kind of 60 at the end wait what
is the move here oh it's C3 that's the
move it's C3
six
huh
scary Five
I don't know which before q1
whoa
really girl really girl
I'm gonna do about that now
as tempted as I am to play V5
I think I'm gonna go here first
okay now I have to go B5
I mean it's obviously a totally unclear
position and it's it's not a given that
this attack succeeds far from a given
actually
the fact that it needs more likely than
not that this attack is totally on sound
but
you know which just seems risky for him
to do this
no what am I doing
yeah my Bishop's not in the game
it's the real problem in this position
foreign
ago
it's hard to anticipate
thank you
on Bishop C4
foreign
let's go
that's it that's it 25 games
that was one of the best matches I've
played in a while
for sure I'm putting that up on YouTube
to the tune of 10 000 views
bullet time
who's next
yeah I was I was praying for Bishops
before because I'd seen this move
I I I was praying for Bishop C4 because
I'd seen this move
um and then I and then that's why I
played H4 actually because here
it's not quite as clean after Bishop C4
it's still the best move
but did I found so many nice moves this
game Bishop F4 was freaking
it's the second move
and then takes and Bishop E3 got the
bishop into the game this is the top
move Bishop C5 I mean everything was
just flowing Knight D4 Queen A5 I mean
everything
yeah now we're okay seven I could have
even played Queen A7 if I wanted to be
classy but then my knight gets trapped
I could play Wei and try to get to 30.
3300
let's play way maybe a little bit
okay he wants bullet
foreign
let's go
he's actually a very dangerous bullet
flyer
this is going to get yeah this is
honestly one of my highest stream
highlights in the last year
and but unfortunately
when I put those matches up on YouTube
they're not very popular so
we'll see maybe
I should title it I beat the world
champion maybe that'll do it or
something
foreign
Jesus
okay that was insane
I mean somehow I always managed to flag
him in the end
I guess when it's your day it's your day
that was a good game by him though
like honestly I was just absolutely on
fire that much that was crazy
I've never beaten him
anywhere near this margin
that was freaking amazing
yeah you just sometimes you get into a
flow and then Everything feels like it
works it's just one of those things rare
rarely happens to me
usually it's the opposite of that just
in ineptitude and incompetence on every
level but
just that once
it was good
such as here
this type of an aptitude
oh my God such a slippery little fudger
oh my God you mother fudge
it's mate holy smokes
foreign
[Music]
what am I doing
taking
no my rain is not gonna last summer
though
I'm donating a little bit to fedo
what
I don't get it takes
everything just working right now
[ __ ]
fc7 Queen D1 unbelievable
and if he goes takes takes takes C7 I
have Queenie one Queen E5
wait
no he has this you [ __ ]
thanks
oh God I almost watered the queen
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
mm-hmm
oh no
dude he's got a bullet
Vladimir is a good little player
yeah
why did I go Rook C5 I could have gone
right first maybe he misses a fork
[Music]
yeah
well finally
[Music]
okay
that was impressive player let's just
say
I was much better at the end game but
okay
oh God
it's another insane move
I should have six unfortunately
okay Pawn down here
and I have no time
foreign
foreign
too slow
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh no this is I'm losing my mind
foreign
I need to be careful to lose my queen
here
Wendy 2 was a nice move to threatened me
okay let's get the hell out of there
so hard I'm up a queen
I feel like I'm losing control of the
game even though I'm not
okay fast fast fast
mastermaster
what I'm doing
I'm running out of I'm running out of
fuel
another one move wonders this much
I mean it is bullet so partially to be
expected
I just walked into this
and walked into that
[Music]
so Queen A1
[Music]
that was a game I absolutely should have
won
[Music]
all right time for a rosin trip
totally winning position there and when
I when I got his Bishop
[Music]
foreign
It's Not Over
I take
this beautiful if it works but does it
work
not sure take take here here oh that's
gorgeous this one word worked
but I needed one with black that's the
thing I'm gonna lose all my rating if I
don't win with black
we keep exchanging exchanging wins
can't exchange wins
we need to win with black
you know [ __ ] I blundered my knight
just kidding
yeah I was convincing wasn't it
wait this has to work doesn't it
I think he'll take
I thought I'd just maybe take
Jack
[ __ ]
Andrew
I guess it's a drone
[Music]
yeah it's a drone
three three three maybe I should stop
here
hmm
foreign
I thought I could take I'm an idiot
and I can't defend against Knight C7 I
guess I have this one though
no I can't defend unbelievable here
no
yeah you shouldn't have gone for the win
there
you should have gone for the draw
foreign
this is winning isn't it
um sure
I don't know the move here
no that was that was like
it's not what I planned to do
essentially
so complicated and he's played so
quickly
because Bishop he's six
oh my gosh
he played this fast
my [ __ ]
foreign
no stalemate
another one in the can
okay let's go and again but okay he's
gonna go Carl
one plus zero is so much fun
I played so much 30 seconds I forgot how
fun bullet is
um
wrong way
okay I'm not oh I could have um
foreign
he's an incredible player in general
Talent is crazy
no no no no no
no
I was already lost yeah
alien luckily I have this
foreign
why would I do that
because I win
oh my lands girl my landscara
foreign
immensely stupid of me to do that
foreign
he can't really move his Rook though
that really helps me
um
wait
foreign
oh my gosh I wondered that
oh my gosh
that was a crazy game
this A4 line is really good by the way
in the modern it's like better for white
and it's it's still very underrated
what
oh
nobody can't no no
there
I think I can even take
he's not slow at all should be
I think I'm just fast
in this case I'm gonna not if I'm gonna
defend him he's quite fast actually
but I'm sure you would be able to flag
him pretty easily
not that hard to do
it's just better safe
all right let's go here
he's pretty decent decently fast
he does primo it's just he's just
sometimes doesn't do it enough
yeah he loves to see four nonsense
okay this time he goes
I like to sack in this position actually
I feel like in a bullet game this makes
perfect sense
let's go E8
probably too slow yeah [ __ ] oh my gosh
wait
here here here here
no that was crappy what am I doing
well that backfired spectacularly
unbelievable where is this all coming
from
not over yet
because it works uh
only once G5
dude he is wildly good
foreign
foreign
here
which perhaps he is but it's very hard
to figure this out and bullet
[Music]
um
foreign
wild complications
but winning for white
he's also kind of going into my type of
positions
foreign
that one I didn't see
hmm
really really
yes really really
oh [ __ ] come on man come on man
just a convoluted position
very convoluted
not as convoluted as
I need something that's convoluted and
then not convoluted
more convoluted than a stretch of
highway and less
convoluted than a I don't know
foreign
thank you Kimmy
you're doing well
I've been a strapped
foreign
[Music]
unbelievable
should be able to hold this though
[Music]
now
[Music]
no no no no no what is he doing why is
he doing it
why is he losing he's trying to lose he
just succeeded
foreign
[Music]
foreign
more guys
[Music]
no you [ __ ] mother God damn it
comes across abroad
okay wait it's not over yet
okay 3400 is literally impossible
I would have to win like another 100
games against them
but I have gotten it before I mean it
just it just depends on the opponent
that was that was sad game right there
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
it's never over that's from from
classical jazz never do do something I'm
bullet again yeah yeah it does manage
okay swindle's opponent but with that
being said I mean I mean does you know
Diana okay let's go here
am I gonna actually win this freaking
game
your face is so weird in the thumbnails
like yeah it's like so weird like you're
so weird
all right last three I said
to make it to 50.
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
shiza
oh your mother your mother
he's such a mother
he's gonna be a good mother
yeah
that's what I meant he's a mother
to two wonderful children
he's both father and mother at the same
time
that's the most pertinently he is a
mother
get the [ __ ] you piece
I just
just freaking puns
no no no no I was a tomato one
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
no no no no
hey mother
that was a great game by Vladimir
oh I I almost wish he
unbelievable I mean some of these have
been crazy
how did I pull that one off
I feel like I'm gonna lose this one
oh my gosh yeah
okay I'm done an exchange but I've got a
lot of activity
so it's not totally over
well he really doesn't want to give away
a single point is he
foreign
how many pawns does he have
oh my gosh she actually is gonna go Rook
H3 I have to go here
oh my gosh I just saw absolutely
everything that came
nah
still me
all right
last last one I'm gonna win
let's try you five this time
I feel like he's figuring this line out
[Music]
um
no but what does that mean from sucks
oh my gosh damn it this is annoying
I have to give up one of the pieces and
um
everything's falling
yeah you definitely figured this line
out unfortunately
pawns again
is easy
trying to hold on here
[Music]
um can I do this
wait
foreign
97 actually wins the piece
oh that was a terrible move
um
let's go fill a crickle all right that's
it guys oh my God I was over 50 games
oh my gosh oh
yeah this was my match today
this was freaking my match
three and a half hours holy [ __ ]
[Music]